bonsoir à tous
fier d'être là même si l'exercice est
difficile alors l'exercice est difficile
parce qu'on a eu des excellents speaker
jusqu'à présent mais l'exercice est
difficile parce que c'est un exercice
inhabituel pour moi puisque je vous
parlais pendant cinq minutes de ma life
de moi et ça c'est pas toujours très
évident alors vous voyez que j'ai choisi
volontairement un titre entre schumpeter
et pretty woman ma théorie d'innovation
qui ne révèle pas du tout mon expertise
en revanche je pense que ce titre relate
assez bien mon quotidien et j'espère
qu'à travers le récit que je vais vous
en faire ce qui n'est pas mon habitude
et bien vous allez pouvoir trouver mon
expertise alors pour débuter ce talk
j'aimerais vous dire que je ne suis ni
joseph schumpeter ni pretty woman mais
un peu des deux à la fois alors en effet
dans mon activité d'enseignant chercheur
j'ai pas l'opportunité d'explorer toute
la journée et finalement de découvrir
des choses nouvelles
alors c'est quand même très regrettable
puisque joseph schumpeter lui même le
grand théoricien l'innovation nous dit
marc quelqu'un qui n'explore pas c'est
quelqu'un qui n'innove pas et qui n'aura
pas de compétitivité future et qui sera
pas en capacité de porter la
compétitivité de la compétitivité future
de son organisation fred nous l'a aussi
dit fortement l'innovation quelque part
c'est d'être encore dans la compétition
demain et c'est donc tout à fait
fondamental alors je vous rassure
évidemment je le fais un peu un jeu le
fait à travers mes publications mais je
ne fais pas complètement
ben pourquoi parce que la recherche
c'est évidemment passionnant mais ça ne
nourrit pas son homme ou plutôt sa femme
donc je suis obligé de faire comme
pretty woman
donc je marche beaucoup à leur parc sur
les trottoirs je cours aussi beaucoup
mais pas après les hommes mon chéri et
dans la salle et du coup je cours après
quoi je cours après le temps 1
quand même un peu pour participer à la
performance évidemment à court terme de
mon organisation
thierry rolando vice présidents
d'université est présent évidemment et
bien il faut que je fasse mon boulot
d'enseignants de dévaluation
animation de réseaux participation à des
conférences etc
pour avoir mon salaire à la fin du mois
mais vont aussi un petit peu plus à
travers la multiplication d'activités et
le problème est le suivant et vous devez
savoir le problème c'est comment je
concilie finalement deux activités aussi
différentes
l'exploration il faut du temps il faut
que je réfléchisse c'est des enjeux de
long terme c'est hyper risqués comme
activité et en même temps on me demande
d'avoir la tête dans le guidon à court
terme pour être toujours toujours plus
performantes et ça c'est un vrai
problème c'est un problème que chacun
vit c'est un problème d'étudiants pour
que je réussisse mon année et il faut
que je me projette dans des métiers de
demain
c'est un problème de dirigeants m'a
effectivement il faut que je sois dans
la course donc il faut que j'innove mais
en même temps il faut la rentabilité
immédiate pour mon entreprise sinon je
vais être out
enfin c'est c'est vrai que préoccupation
de tout le monde eh bien je crois que
j'ai trouvé la solution
alors la solution comment je fais
concrètement et ben je vais utiliser les
théories et en particulier une théorie
de l'innovation qui finalement me donne
de très bons conseils
alors la première chose que je fais
c'est que j'ai deux bureaux alors vous
allez me dire c'est le grand luxe à
l'université maintenant c'est pas le
grand luxe à l'université parce que ces
deux bureaux partagés mais en même temps
le fait d'avoir deux bureaux ça me
contre 1 avoir finalement deux activités
bien séparés en termes de structure
c'est ce qu'on appelle théoriquement
l'ambidextrie structurelles le bureau
pour l'exploration le bureau de la
recherche et le bureau pour le quotidien
donc ça c'est une bonne façon de faire
et quand je vois qu'il ya trop de
poussière sur un bureau là je commence à
ma folie deuxième technique possible
c'est aussi ce que je pratique s'appelle
l'ambidextrie contextuel on en a parlé
j'ai appris que j'étais une cela chez
eux en fait j'ai mon agenda que je vais
découpée en deux temps
évidemment là vous voyez que c'est pas
équilibrée parce que j'exploite beaucoup
plus que j'explore à mon grand regret
mais en même temps c'est assez pratique
de se dire maintien sur une journée une
semaine ou un mois
je vais pouvoir organiser mon activité
et prendre le temps qu'il faut
par exemple moi je le prends quand même
tant pis je le dis à thierry roland dos
je ne donne plus de cours à partir de
janvier pour justement être en capacité
de faire de la recherche
et puis quand ça fonctionne pas parce
que malheureusement on a quand même bien
la tête dans le guidon et bien là j'ai
une autre technique et là c'est
redoutable sais que je vais faire appel
à mon réseau et donc comment ça se passe
c'est évidemment quand j'arrête pas de
courir
eh bien je fais appel à mes doctorants
dont karine et là par exemple c'est une
doctorante et on va demander à nos
doctorants de nous aider à trouver une
nouvelle idée ce qu'ils ont des idées
assez génial et doctorants ou alors je
vais je vais faire appel à mes co
auteurs qui ont eu tout le temps pour
réfléchir parce qu'ils sont à l'étranger
sont payés à réfléchir toute la journée
contrairement à nous donc voilà donc
l'histoire c'est ça c'est déjà si vous
voulez être ambidextre housse housses
lâcheuse je sais pas en tout cas si vous
voulez ambidextre participer à la fois à
la performance de votre organisation à
court terme et aussi garantir finalement
c'est une position forte à long terme
faire en sorte qu'elle soit toujours
dans la course
faire en sorte qu'elle soit sur de
nouveaux marchés qu'elle sort en
capacité d'inventer de nouvelles
technologies de nouvelles innovations
managériale nouvelles formes de manager
les hommes
eh bien j'ai trois conseil à vous donner
qui sont issus de la littérature
premièrement ne restez pas scotché dans
votre bureau et essayer d'aller voir les
petits collègues les copains autour de
vous et jouez donc le cross fonctionnel
deuxième chose très simple il faut
réserver du temps il faut réserver du
temps pour essayer de cogiter donc je
crois que c'est une thématique est très
présente parmi l'ensemble de nos de nos
tedx il faut prendre le recul nécessaire
et pas se laisser envahir par le
quotidien et le troisième est évidemment
conseil qui est tout à fait fondamental
c'est qu'il faut que vous construire un
réseau et je crois que le tedx et est là
pour ça mais il faut construire un
réseau avec plein de compétences
complémentaires et comme ça quand on a
un déficit et ben on va chercher chez le
copain de quoi le combler donc ça y est
vous comprenez quel est mon expertise
mon expertise ça se voit pas mais je
suis ambidextre
mais ma vraie expertise en fait c'est
pal ambidextrie ma vraie expertise c'est
l'enseignement et celle transfert des
théories en management de l'innovation
et là je viens de vous en ci
né en cinq ou six minutes chrono une
théorie qui est importante en innovation
qui s'appelle la théorie dans l'ue d'ex
tri organisationnel et qui nous
enseignent comment concilier au mieux
des logiques contradictoires des
logiques de court terme l'exploitation
ou des logiques de long terme innovation
à travers trois leviers
alors j'espère que vous avez compris et
puis si c'est pas le cas c'est que vous
n'êtes pas très bon élève et il est
important que vous me rejoignent et dans
mon prochain cours en management de
l'innovation
[Applaudissements]